today we have distinguished professor
of physics from ucsd the
chancellor's professor brian king
who is instrumental with the
simon's foundation and their work with
telescope down in chile tell us more
about that brian
so yeah i am the uh the direct the
director of what's called the simon's
observatory project
uh office in san diego which is a
consortium
of over 40 universities building the
most ambitious
telescope ever made to search for the
cosmic
uh beginning the spark that ignited the
big bang we
as pictured behind me if you can see in
the video the site
in the high atacama desert of northern
chile at 17
200 feet above half the atmospheric
pressure that we feel at sea level
we're building the most ambitious
observatory ever made to look back to
our cosmic origins
that's super awesome so you know with
this
knowledge uh you know what what type of
scientific uh research do you think
we'll be able to do
10 20 30 years down the road from this
so
we have an experience of moore's
law-like growth
in astronomy and it comes along with it
a budget that is astronomical as well
and my feeling is as long as we can keep
the budget increasing with the science
capabilities and technological
advancements
we will be able to unlock mysteries that
our ancestors
even as early as 40 50 years ago
couldn't have possibly dreamed of when
we discover the composition the age the
expansion
rate of the universe it will allow us in
the future
to really make distinctions that were
purely the realm of science fiction
or even philosophy theology and religion
just a few decades ago namely did the
universe have a single beginning
that's perhaps the one question that i'd
most like to ask god of god exists or
nature mother nature uh the the question
of how did the universe come to exist
and
what if anything can be said about what
happened on the tuesday before the big
bang
does that question even make sense folks
like stephen hawking said that's
nonsensical you can't ask about that
time itself came into existence but we
have really no idea if
stephen hawking was right and this
experiment the simon's observatory
and our hotly competitive experiments
you know we're not the only people that
are
smart capable and uh and able to build
experiments like this
there's a hot bed of competition in this
field to discover what happened at the
beginning of time
because if successful the team that
would do it perhaps would win
the most exalted prize that humanity has
to offer which is the nobel prize
yes now let's get to that that has been
something that as a i hate to say has
defined your career losing the nobel
prize you know you wrote a book on it
about a year and a half ago and you know
it's something that has become you know
a part of you
are are you gonna are you gonna outgrow
this or is this going to be your
obsession till death
yeah so the book i um i urge people to
read it not not
because it's you know going to make me
so wealthy uh that i will no longer need
the nobel prize million dollar
award money but really because it's a
story of a memoir of a scientist
striving to do the ultimate in
in in my field and it's applicable to
any field if you're trying to make
partner in a law firm if you're trying
to get the keeler williams you know
uh re seller of the year if you're
trying to get
uh the to be class president in your in
your college
what does it mean to come up with sure i
think that was in this politics so i
guess the question is how much of the
noble causes politics in the end then
there's a tremendous amount there's a
new book that because i wrote this book
i'm
got interested and invited to do all
sorts of opportunities one of which was
to blurb to write the blurb on the back
of a book
that's coming out in november by a woman
who's become a friend i've never met her
she lives in norway
and she wrote a new book called
betraying the nobel prize betraying the
nobel
about all the evils that she perceives
in the corruption
of the nobel peace prize where it's been
awarded to war mongers to
women and men who are responsible for
deaths and and so forth and
we make she makes the point and i've
made the point that the nobel prize has
an obligation to live up to these lofty
ideals that
both alfred nobel created it for and
also that society holds it
to do in other words the nobel prize in
any field
is the most prestigious award that you
could possibly win it's more prestigious
than the oscars
it's more you know the model is pretty
fantastic i'll say
but you can only win the field medal if
you're 40 and younger and it's only
given every five years or so
so yes it is it is extremely prestigious
but uh but there's all sorts of
additional restrictions on the fields
medal some say it's even worse than the
nobel prize
you know uh for me though the nobel
prize is a manifestation of
the ideals of the nordic people i have
worked with the nordic innovation house
and done extreme amounts of research
into the nordic countries
and they have a tradition of hard work
diligence and education that is really
quite unique to those
uh countries into that area of the world
so you know
it's it's uh you know it's a fantastic
prize
but do you want to talk about bicep two
and what happened there
with the dust so just before we move on
i mean what you said is true
but of course it's not just you know a
prize given away uh to norwegian people
although you're a lot more
to swedish people is actually sweden's a
lot more populous than norway as you
know
and the swedish prizes are the four five
nobel prizes
um that are given out and the peace
prize is the only one that's given in
norway
but uh but you're right there is a work
ethic and integrity of that
but the nobel prize is now come to be
the thing that determines how much
funding gets
applied in places like taiwan in in in
california and tenured decisions that
are made
and naming streets after people's names
it's no longer
restricted to mere you know scandinavian
interests it used to be you're right and
actually if you look at the google
engram search and you search on pulitzer
prize versus nobel prize for a long time
the pulitzer prize was much more
prestigious than the nobel prize
i don't think we would say it is today i
think if you gave the
chance between a person winning the
nobel prize in literature or the
pulitzer prize
there's not even a competition there's
movies say again
well i would agree uh nobel prizes uh
does it not have an out like hollywood
had its me too movement
because in particular hollywood has such
outsized impact on our culture you know
hollywood movies only make only um
not going to sneeze at it but it make up
that 99 billion dollars a year
but they have an impact way beyond the
market cap of stocks that are
or companies that are that are worth 10
times that amount so
um and that's because so they have a
different obligation which is why the
metoo movement was so important
to to really you know draw attention to
to corruption and problems within
the hollywood scene and now with the
book that i wrote and the book that
my friend uni tortini has written about
the peace prize you know we're hoping
that we'll use the prestige of these
prizes to reform them so that they can
be the beacon of hope that alfred nobel
intended them to be
um so bicep two was an experiment that's
over my shoulder here
it's at the south pole antarctica which
is the most southern point in the
in on the planet uh say again
how much time did you spend in
antarctica i've been there twice and you
spend about a month each time unless you
want to spend
11 months of your life you have to get
out by february
because after february it's too cold for
planes to take off again they can land
but their uh their fluids or hydraulics
will freeze up and seize up and that
will destroy this military cargo planes
that get us down there so the government
doesn't allow flights in or out after
february
which is the beginning of their win you
know their fall
down the southern hemisphere we go there
because it's one of the best places on
earth next to the chilean atacama desert
that i showed before
to do astronomical research you have an
uninterrupted
unobstructed view into the cosmos except
perhaps
by a little bit of the atmosphere that
is residual above our heads
but you might not know this but the
south pole is at an elevation of almost
10 000 feet above sea level because of
all the millennia of ice that have
accumulated
and brought us up in this platform of
cold dry
almost snow free as ironically
environment that allows us in
a six-month window where there's no
sunlight whatsoever
above the horizon so it's a phenomenal
place to do astronomy
which is why i designed this bicep two
experiment with my colleagues at caltech
and elsewhere
to look for the birth pangs
of the big bang and how it came to be
hoping concomitantly with that
i personally was hoping i'd win the
nobel prize i make no secret of that
but now having come through a brush with
it and
really uh being asked to nominate the
winners of the nobel prize soon after i
was disquali i mean spoiler alert
the title is losing the nobel prize not
winning the nobel prize
uh and because of that i had an
encounter that really caused me to
reflect on why did i want to win it so
much
why was it so important to my soul as
a human being to win this relatively
you know abstract thing opaque
non-transparent prize that why does it
have such
why did it have such an influence over
me and what can be done about it in the
future
well let's talk about uh the dust
specifically
and how it misled the bicep 2 team do
you want to go into that
yeah so the uh search that we had was
really commit you know thought to be a
fool's errand in the beginning we never
thought we would actually detect
anything
and if we did detect something we
thought oh well we'll you know
we'll take the time we'll go back we'll
double check it we'll make sure that
everything is is correct and that we
actually did see what we saw we said but
we're not going to see it anyway
because the signals that we're trying to
detect alex are at the
parts per billion level in other words
the south pole is freezing freezing cold
but even it is 10 billion times hotter
if you like than the signal size that we
were attempting to measure
from a emanation from this early epoch
in the universe
that that came shortly after the big
bang if true
and that's uh these are called
gravitational waves they
make a certain pattern on the cosmic
microwave background radiation so i
describe all that along with the memoir
component of my book
is really a description uh for the first
time of why this is so important to look
for the signal
and what it would be as a harbinger as
an imprimatur
of the earliest epoch in the universe's
history that would ever be accessible to
humankind
and so the stakes could not be higher
and yet we thought ah we're never going
to detect it but let's try it anyway
because
you miss all the shots you don't take as
wayne gretzky said so in our case
we built this experiment and we never
thought we'd see something we built a
successor to it that upgraded it added
you know like
increasing the processor speed you know
like the iphone every couple of years
you got upgraded we upgraded it it
became bicep2
and then we made a discovery that
wouldn't go away in other words we tried
to prove ourselves wrong
we detected the very signal that we were
trying to detect
and whenever that happens you have to be
very very nervous because
the the as richard feynman nobel
laureate used to say
you know you know you have to be very
careful and the first principle is not
to fool yourself and you're the easiest
person in the world to fool
meaning you have to look for all the
ways you could be wrong as a scientist
not all the ways you could be right
so we looked at that including what's
called dust which is really nothing more
than
tiny micro meteorite particles that are
the relic remnants of a previous
supernova that lived in our galaxy
not far away from perhaps where our
solar system is
and the these dusty materials are
pervasive throughout the cosmos they're
in stars or galaxies solar systems
and uh and because of that we knew we'd
have to confront it but we didn't have
the data we needed desperately to get
data that was only sensitive to dust and
not sensitive to the big bang signals we
sought
we didn't have that data a competitor
experiment did have the data
and i described in the book the agony
the anguish of like dealing with your
competitor who wants to win the nobel
prize as much or more than you they
spent a billion
euros on their project called the planck
satellite we only had 10 million dollars
but you know we're competing kind of
david institute
no this is the european space agency
this is the
european answer to nasa they launched a
satellite in 2009
to do just this in part to measure these
signals from the wispy imprints of
inflation and the early universe's
cosmic microwave background and they had
claimed originally that they would beat
us to it so
it was very much in a race but they had
extra capability with the extra funding
with the extra
you know a thousand people on their team
we we had 49
and were you know brilliant and we were
able to do it we actually in the end did
better than they did
much better than they did but they had
one critical missing piece
which was they had sort of an
experimental window
only that was sensitive to sensitive
only to dust
meaning that we thought the signal that
we saw
was the cosmic signal plus the dust and
we wanted to get rid of the dust
subtract the dust and that would leave
us with but you can't go out and put a
vacuum cleaner in space
instead all you can do is put a as is
make another experiment that's sensitive
to dust and that is
basically another type of component of
your telescope which they had which we
didn't
it turns out they were only sensitive to
dust pretty much
and we were pretty much only sensitive
to the combination of dust plus the cmb
this cosmic microwave background so we
asked them we said
uh please give us shares with you know
share your data with us and they refused
and at the time i thought that meant
that they had
this cosmic signal too and so why share
anything with us it wouldn't benefit
them
it turns out they didn't have the cosmic
signal they really only had the dust
signal and only
after we published the paper had a press
conference had results published
on the front page of the new york times
did we realize that what we had detected
was not
the cosmic signal alone at most it was
the cosmic signal plus a healthy amount
of dust
and in the end we essentially retracted
that there was any cosmic signal in
there whatsoever
and that the signal that we saw was
predominantly dominated by
the dust oh no
sorry about that yeah that's what
happens with experiments unfortunately
you know with my work with machine
learning it's uh noise i guess my
version of dust is noise and
it can very much uh mess with your
research
and of course the you know fallout can
be painful i imagine
uh you know the months afterwards was
not an easy one for you
and uh you know but you've learned from
it and you've
clearly gotten uh stronger if you will
i've got to jump to two
things one if in 10 or 20 years we're
able to put a telescope on the moon
how much will that increase our ability
yeah there'll be a tremendous
advance for astronomy if we could get
something on the far side of the moon
it wouldn't be exactly like my branch of
astronomy that's not necessarily best
done
on the far side of the moon it's better
done in space probably a lot cheaper but
there are
experiments searching for an allied
signal similar to what i do it would
take a little bit longer to describe
related to what's called the epoch of
reionization which is a preceding epoch
to
the formation of galaxies and that needs
to be done there because the signals
that they look for alex are in the
tens of megahertz range in other words
they're the same as like an fm
you know a radio station or a cell phone
or something like their garage door
openers
and so those get polluted and
contaminated whereas on the far side of
the moon that you can't even see the
earth
and so it'll be completely shielded and
they'd be able to get power energy
resources and it would be quite a stable
place so that's
thought to be one of the best places in
the world to look for the first
formation
of the actual structures in the universe
that came
about a million years after the big bang
also while i have you by the way last
spring some
chinese scientists came out with some
research saying that uh
sonic waves could move uh actual
particles do you think
that's real or do you think that's only
theoretical uh
i'm not familiar with that so i probably
shouldn't talk about it
sure i'll definitely send it to you
afterwards though very interesting stuff
it was shared uh
by an mit friend of mine so we'll get to
that later my last question
is you know uh aliens life outside of
planet earth where are you on that
tell us your feelings uh i have a
controversial feeling i feel like aliens
don't exist
and like and i've done the kind of math
and prescriptions about that i give a
talk at what's called the seti institute
in northern california about um some
some
answers some solutions to the fermi
paradox so fermi paradox says that
there's trillions of planets in the
observable universe um
and would they some of them have lived a
lot longer than we have uh
the drake equation suggests a certain
number of them that should exist why
haven't we seen them where are they
fermi enrico fermi noble laureate
famously said you know where are they
and my answer
is that they probably don't exist uh the
hurdles
required to make life that's different
than us if we
there was life created on earth and then
that somehow spread throughout the solar
system that's called panspermia
that that is theoretically possible um
there is no evidence necessarily that
that's happened
but um but there's that there's you know
entire civilizations with technological
life
that have shielded themselves outside of
the ability of us to detect
and are somehow lurking around i feel
that probability is quite low
um and it's even lower if you try to
assign it ab initio
the formation of life and then the
development of technology
just describing you know a 0.1
probability for 10 different events
you know 0.1 to the 10th power you start
to get into
a lower number probability wise than the
total number of habitable planets
in the in our at least in our galaxy
forget about other gala we'll never be
able to cut in contact with other
galaxies
um you know wormholes and things they're
really fun to talk about on you know
sci-fi movies but
in reality we have no evidence that they
even exist occam's razor we are alone
uh so no this was a a wonderful
conversation
and thank you you're absolutely
brilliant guy and i really hope
uh you win your nobel prize one day and
uh maybe you too
oh thank you so much so uh stay safe
be well great talking to you bye